それからこの偈の説明に入ります
ナパレーサンヴィローマーニ
ヴィローマっていうのは正しくないっていう
もうごちゃごちゃしたこと
行為なんですね もう理性に合わない無茶苦茶な行為ですね
行いですね いわゆる間違いですね
過ちですね まぁ仏教ではあれちょっとおかしいんじゃないの？と思う行為ですよ
パレーサン 他人の 他人の過ちをな
気にするなよと なってないでいい
次 ナパレーサンカタカタム
で カタカタムという単語の意味
カタっていうのは行ったこと
アカタンっていうのは行わなかったこと
それからパレーサンですね
他人の だから他人のですけど
日本語になると言うとちょっと違うんですね
他人がになりますけど
まあ他人がやったこと
やらなかったことは まあな
関係ないんだと それだけで全然意味が日本や日本では日本語では通らないかも
だから他人がどんな過ちやってるのか
どんな犯罪しているのか
どんな間違ってることをやってるのかどうか
あなたに関係ないでしょうと
他人が自分の義務をちゃんと果たしているのか
あるいは義務を果たしてないのかとかね
やるべきことをちゃんとやっているのか
やるべきことをちゃんとやってないのではないかとかね
そんなことをぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ気にするなかれということなんです
人のこと アッタナヲアヴェッケーヤ
自分を見なさいよと カタニアカターニチャ
自分がやってること やってないことは何なのかと
それだけ見なさいよと
それは道ですよ 私から見ればそれほど完璧にも語れないと思いますよ
例えば 人が悪いことをするとどうする
どうすればいいかとか
みんな一生懸命考えてるでしょうに
答えがある？犯罪を撲滅するためにどうすればいいかと
誰が撲滅した？その石原さんとかね
もうまあもうなんて言いますか
この万引きなんか これはもうものすごい犯罪ですよとかね
あれやこれやとかもうごちゃごちゃ言ってますけど
まあまあまとめに喋ってはいるんですけど
これはもう警察も手に負えないんだから
もう何ももうすぐもうそのまま家に返しちゃいますよと
万引きしちゃうと そこでもう東京から上げて
東京の方がすごい刺激があるんだからといって
東京に来てみんな万引きやってるんだと
まあ警察ももう言ったっても意味がないし
もうあまりにもやりすぎだから
みんなもう 本当は2 日間ぐらい警察でもうもう逮捕してもらって
それからもう帰してあげた方がみんなあの苦しみを味わうんだから二度とやりたくないやらないんだけど
そんなこと今できない状態だと
だから犯罪意識はもうあってほしいとか何とかとか
まあまあ言ってることはまあそれなりに
まあちゃんと真面目なことなんですけど
私が聞きたいのは そういう意味であんた方はこの犯罪なくしてるんでしょうかと
なくせないでしょうね
それで彼にまた性犯罪に対しても質問されましたけどね
まあそれもすごい真面目に
ものすごいもう知識的には本人は答え出しますけど
まあそれは政治家としてのを言える範囲では言いますけど
やっぱりそういうことに何かするのも政治家の仕事ですけど
それ何もできないんですよ
結局は 彼がその場合言った面白いことっていうのは
まあ異常な人間がいろいろいるんだと
アメリカだったら性犯罪の場合はすごい厳しくて
日本はあんまりにももう寛容で認めすぎて
人権とかなんとかで 結局犯罪者の人権が守るんであって
被害者の人権はどうでもいいことになっちゃうとか
そういうことを言いまして
それでまた知識的にも
まあ人間っていうのは
まあみんないろいろまあ変な性格はついてきて生まれるんだと
で コレクターは一部だよと
いろんなコレクターたちがいるでしょ？あれも同じことやと
だからもう本当に ただ性的な犯罪を起こしただけで異常な人間ということではなくて
まあみんな異常やと その中でこれは困りますよと
コレクターの場合はそんなに困ることはないんです
ゴミコレクターは困りますけど
それ見るんだからね もうある東南の人がね
ゴミを集めて捨ててるゴミを持ってきて自分の家に入れて
それで大変で問題が起きて
もう火事にもなって もうとにかくもう役所の役所の方でもうなんとか綺麗にすること
もうなんかトラック 20台分ですよ
何ヶ月もかけて いいコレクターなんですけどね
もう だからみんな精神的な異常なところは持っている
だからそこは切手のコレクターやら骨董品のコレクターやら誰も悪口言わないし
絵画のコレクターやらもう偉そうに褒めるし
ゴミのコレクターだったらもういろいろ悪口言うし
異常的ないろいろ性的悔いがある人にとっては
ものすごくいろんなこと言ったりだとか
やっぱりお釈迦様もみんな同じということで扱ったところは立派だなと思いましたけどね
偏見なくものを見て 偏見なくではなくてね
それなりにちゃんとした知識人としてのことは見てはいるんですけどね
でも解決法を持ってないんですよ
一応 さすが立派に答えてはいるんですけどね
新聞記者が出す質問には
だからといってね どうするのかと
だから性犯罪 犯罪はダメだよとかね
痴漢はダメですよとかね
で 事故ゼロ運動とかね
やってるでしょうに 事故ゼロ運動といって
あっちこっち看板かけて
あの 何て言いますか たすきをつけちゃったりして
あの 宅急便の車にも全部まあ事故ゼロ
だから今月は事故ゼロという看板かけた時点でもうちょっとおかしいでしょうに
1ヶ月間事故ゼロ運動をやっていて
あの あの 何 黒猫なんとかという宅急便の会社
あれってあんた方おかしいじゃないかと聞きたいんだけど
1ヶ月終わったらどうするの？だからもう犯罪をなくす年とかね
もうなんとかそんな一年だけって
それからやってもいいのかというね
言っただけでうまくいかない
ポイントはこちら言ってますよ
答えはね これ他人を直そうとしてるんですよ
他人を直そうとしてもできないんですよ
他人が何するかということは
こちらで管理できないでしょうに
盗まないよと言うくらいはいいんだけど
言えるんだけど その人は聞くか聞かないか分かったもんじゃないでしょうに
聞いても実行するかしないかと分かったもんじゃないでしょうに
あるいは実行しようとか
思っても条件によってできなかったということもあるでしょうに
あるいは後で気が変わったというのはどうしますかね
時々ね 反省会してもう刑罰を受けて
ちゃんともう何て言いますか
あれは更生じゃない 更生してちゃんと更生して
まともな人間に変わり戻りましたと社会にと
それは信頼できませんよ
それでも また物事うまくいかなくなっちゃうと
また気が変わったよと
私は真面目な人間にいようと思ったんですけど
うまくいかなかったと
また犯罪を始めたんだと
と言えばどうしますかね
そんなのは卒鳥でしょうに
だから黒柳さんはね  1ヶ月間事故ゼロ運動をやってるんじゃなくて
一人一人運転手が自分で一人で人は何言おうとも関係なく
私はもう宅急便の運転手だから
私は一生事故ゼロで仕事するんだよと
自分で決めれば何の圧力もないんですよ
その場合は それで自分の自慢でしょ
事故を起こさずきちんと仕事をする
これは私の決まりだと
だから毎日気をつけて運転することによって
その人は喜びを感じる
会社から命令されて 今月は事故ゼロ運動だよと言うと
ストレスかかっている
あまり面白くないんですよ
もう一つ規則が入りましたからね
普段も忙しくてやりにくい仕事なのに
あの過労になるまでやってるのに
みんな徹夜してうるたくなんで
それからまた朝もあっちこっちも配らなくちゃいけないし
そこまでやってる上で
あんた事故ゼロ運動やと
今月はと さらにストレスかかるんですよ
だから正しく生きる方法っていうのは
人のことはどうでもいいということなんです
その私に関係ないんだと
私がちゃんと義務を果たしているのか
やるべきことをやっているのか
あるいはそれをサボっているのか
やってはいけないことを私はやっているのかと
自分だけの問題なんですよ
そうなるとうまくいきます
だから日本では万引きはもうどうにもなりませんよ
私たちはもうやってもやってみようかなと思ったことがないんです
その その子供頃とかね
思ったこともない これなら取れそうとかね
それはこれはもう人のものを取ってはあかんと
これは情けないんだと
だからもうどこに行ったって
店に行ったっても もう全然その気にはなりません
騙してはいけないとかね
嘘言ってはいけないとかね
ちょこちょこちょこちょこ喧嘩してはいけないとかね
それは自分の問題として扱っているんだから
別に すごい楽に 生きていられるんですよ
だからこの ずっとこの自分のことを棚に上げて他人に対してごちゃごちゃ批判するというね
こういう説教っていうのは世界でいくらでもある
新聞なんかを開けてみると
こうするべきではないか
するべきではない その話ばっかしで
しっかりとは言わないんですよ
しっかりと言うと結構きついんですけどね
だからそうであって あるべきです
なんとかとか みんなよく読んですごくいいなとか
それで終わっちゃうんです
まあ一応ね また心理的にも人間というのはね
あの自分が正しいというね
思って行動するんですよ
だから悪いことをした人も自分が正しいことをやったと思っている
自分が正しいと思ってるんだから
世の中みんな間違ってるように見えるんですね
万引きする人にとって万引きしない人が間違ってますよ
あの いろいろ警報とかいろんなシステム今あるでしょうね
あれ間違ってますね 何だうるさいと
なんでカメラがついているんでしょうかと
そうすると知恵比べで
もうカメラがついてあっても
あの なんか電気的な何か今機械もね
もうあの 生産するところにね
ついてあったりしてね
そこはどうやってごまかしていくのかとかね
そこで考えて万引きしようとする
だからする側が自分が正しいことをやってうまくいったと成功したらね
思っちゃうし だからいつでも人の間違いばっかり探してるんですね
人の間違いを探すっていうことは
ものすごい人格がないってことなんです
もう人格は成り立ちません
一応 初めからもうゼロ
そういう性格があると
あの人はこんなことを
この人はこんなこととかね
あれが悪いんじゃないか
これが悪いんじゃないかとか
こういう評論家的な生き方
それではもう自分の人格はもうクタクタ壊れているってことなんです
もう自分を見ないんだからね
だから自分を見てみなさいと
それはすごい客観的で具体的でしょうね
自分の心ですから 逆に例えば世の中もいいことをやってるんだったら
私もやりますよという感覚があるでしょうに
みんな正直だったら私も正直になるぞと
そんな話ある？それは正直にならないための理由でしょうに
誰も不正をやってないんだったら私もやりませんよと
そんなのは誰でもそうでしょうね
それだったら 逆にみんな嘘をついているんだからしょうがないのではないかと
ということは 自分みんな言ってるんだから自分は嘘をついている
嘘をつくと みんな不正やってるんだから自分も不正行為をすると
その場合は日本人は外国なんかに行って
目安じゃみんなやってるんだからっていうことで
みんなやってるんだからって悪いことが正しくなるはずがないでしょうに
だったら法律で決めてほしいんですよ
犯罪であろうとも みんなやってるんだったらOKですと
そういう法律もないし
法律はあってもみんな犯罪を起こしているならば
お手上げ どうするもどうすることもできなくなるんですよ
みんなそっちを万引きするんだったら
もうどうにもならんでしょうに
できることはその場で撃ち殺せっていうぐらいなんで
でないと手に負えないんだから
もう逮捕したって意味がないで現行犯で
毎日人 人 千人ぐらい逮捕できんだから
国そのだったら国のアパートはものすごく
もう四分の三ぐらい減らして全部刑務所にするしかないんです
国民はみんな犯罪を起こすんだから
町を刑務所へと もう刑務所は政府が作ったっても
もうほんのどこかどこかで
もう何人かしかもうそこで受け入れられないでしょうに
それぐらい犯罪が少なかったらありがたいことで
もうでもこれじゃもうないでしょうに
だから犯罪がもう増えちゃうと
たとえ法律があっても警察がいても
もう見て見ぬふりしか
ふりするしかなくなっちゃうんですね
だから世の中で人間が正しく生きていきたければ
まぁ人のことは放っておいた方がいいんです
棚に上げた方が 人のことを棚に上げて自分のことを気にした方が全てうまくいきます
だから この単純な二行で
お釈迦様がこの世界で道徳倫理語っているんだけど
そこはうまくいかないことをね
道徳倫理っていうのはこういうふうに守るものであると二行で教えているんです
それには微妙にでも矛盾も何もない
だからみんなのことを気に
サンレイクすったっていう経典がありましてね
みんな嘘をついているんだと
しかしここで私は頑張るんだぞと
嘘つかないようにと それが仏教の道なんです
世間の道はみんな嘘をついているのはしょうがないでしょう
これは守るしかないんだということでしょう
仏道の場合は逆で 我々バカじゃない
知ってます みんな嘘をつくわ
泥棒もするわ よこしまな行為もするわとかね
みんなのことを見ると
全然もう相手にならん
もうだらしないと知ってます
汚れているんだ 近寄ってもいけませんと
だからみんなと仲良く一緒になるぞってそこはないんです
だから頑張ってるんだよと
誘惑してもしても 仏教の理屈ではもう勝てませんよ
例えばまあ酒なんか悪くないでしょうって
みんな飲んでるでしょうにと
でも仏教とはね あなたの話聞いて酒飲んだって地獄に落ちる時は私でしょうと
あんたその時何てかやってくれますかと
だから私は地獄に落ちたくないんだと
あんた誰ですかと この場合は嘘をついてもいいです
この場合は不正をしなくちゃあかんでしょうとかね
言ったってあなた誰ですか？と
こんなことバレたらひどい目にあうのは私でしょうと
あんたその時助けに来れるかと
今も私の助けを頼んでいるんだから
例えば不正をやらせるんでしょ？会社なんかでは上司が部下に
バカな部下もやる あんた今も自分でできないくせに私に悪いことを頼んでるんだと
もしバレたらあんた何もやってくれないでしょうと
私は逮捕されたらあなた私の代わりに行くんですかと
私の子供に 家族に永久的に不名誉になることをあんた何かやってくれるんですかと
私の子供は学校でいじめられると
お前はお前の父親がもう退職されたでしょうとか言われると
あんたなんかやってくれるかと
いい加減にしなさいと言えばいいでしょうに
だからもうしっかり生きてられますよ
ブッダの理屈で生きているならば
そういう人には何も言えませんし
かえって信頼するしかないんです
そういう人を それぐらいしっかりしている人だったら
もう別に契約書を書いたりなんとかなくたって信頼できます
どんな会社でそういう人を雇ったっても大丈夫です
会社は繁栄する 何でもやってくれる人をあなたクビやと
私の命令に従う誰 何でも従う人を雇うぞと言っちゃうとどうなるかわからないんだからね
上司があれこれと命令したっても
正しくない法律に合わない命令には逆らう部下がいた方が安全です
その時も上司を直す気もしぶりではなくて
自分の身の安全を図るということなんです
悪いことをしたら地獄に落ちるのはお母さんじゃないでしょうに
自分でしょうに だから世の中でそういうとんでもないことを考えてますよ
平均だから悪いことをする
アダムとイブが神様に逆らったんだからといって
我々はその罰を受けなくちゃいけないんだと
同じ理屈で 自分たちが何やっても他の誰かが受けるでしょうということになるでしょう
悪いことはした人が受けるんであって
だから自分がいろんな悪いことをすると
お母さんが地獄に落ちるということはないんです
ですからもう自分の心を見なさいと
他人に指をさすなよと
心理的な微妙なところも
やっぱり他人 私が正しいというね
悪いのはあいつやという態度が心にあるんだから
そこは瞑想で直らなくちゃいけないんですね
道徳的なところは簡単に直ります
そこは平気で一芸ぐらいで十分でしょう
あまりね